ابدا معك وائل طبعا عظم الله اجرك وصبرك
الله ما هي اخر التطورات في
غزه بارك الله فيكم شكر الله سعيكم ربنا
سبحانه وتعالى
يتقبل ويربط على
القلوب دائما وابدا الاوضاع في قطاع غزه
متفجره والاحداث متتاليه خصوصا مع هذا
التحليق المكثف للطائرات الحربيه
والطائرات
المسيره بالتاكيد هناك سلسله من الغارات
الاسرائيليه شهدتها منطقه خانيونس على وجه
التحديد على مدار الساعات القليله الماضيه
كانتت اصوات الانفجارات متتاليه جدا في
هذه المنطقه في قلب مدينه خانيونس وايضا
في اجزاء اخرى من المحافظه باعتبار ان هذه
الاصوات مصدرها كما يبدو غارات اسرائيليه
جويه وقصف مدفعي اسرائيلي فضلا عن عمليات
تفجير كما يبدو يقوم بها جيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي لمنشات ومنازل وبعض المنشات في
في في مدينه غزه كان قد زرع فيها الغام
يقوم بتفجيرها وهو الامر الذي يصدر اصواتا
شديده جدا وا تشبه القنابل
الارتجاجيه حتى الان حسب المصادر الطبيه
الفلسطينيه اجمالي هذه الغارات التي
شهدتها محافظه خانيونس اكثر من 71 شهيد
على الاقل حتى الان وهناك عدد كبير من
الجرحى ويجري الحديث عن وجود شهداء في بعض
المناطق لكن لا تستطيع سيارات الاسعاف ولا
رجال الدفاع المدني الوصول اليهم لانتشاله
بحيث انه لا يسمح لاي متحرك لاي مواطن
الوصول الى تلك المناطق التي يصنفها جيش
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي على انها مناطق ساخنه
او مناطق اشتباك او مناطق حمراء لكن المهم
ان الوضع متفجر في محافظه خانيونس وتحديدا
في مدينه غز في مدينه خانيونس وهذا الامر
يشي بان كثير من الغارات الاسرائيليه يمكن
ان تحدث وبالتالي يرتفع اعداد الشهداء
والاحصائيه الصادره من الجهات الطبيه في
منطقه الوسطى بالتاكيد الوضع لا يختلف
كثيرا هناك استهداف لمنازل المواطنين
وايضا استهداف لمواطنين فلسطينيين وقصف
مدفعي الامر الذي ادى الى سقوط اعداد من
الشهداء والجرحى في هذه المنطقه التي يبدو
ان جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي خلال الايام
الماضيه يركز في قصفه المدفعي وفي بعض
التوغ على هذه المنطقه وبالتالي هذا يتسبب
في موجات نزوح لا سما من المناطق الشرقيه
لهذه المحافظه تحديدا في مخيمي المغازي
والبريج وسط قطاع غزه الى جانب بعض
المناطق فينا الاجزاء الغربيه للمحافظه
تحديدا شمال النصيرات
والزوايده وبطبيعه الحال المغرا وج حر
الديك هذه المناطق كلها اصبحت يعني مناطق
ملتهبه جدا بفعل الغارات الاسرائيليه
والاعتداءات الاسرائيليه التي لا تتوقف
ابدا في المقابل بالتاكيد المقاومون
الفلسطينيون يستمرون في مواجهه هذه
الاعتداءات الاسرائيليه لا سما مواجهه
الاليات الاسرائيليه التي تحاول التقدم في
مناطق مثل احياء منطقه خانيونس مدينه ينه
خان يونس وايضا تنفيذ بعض العمليات ضد هذه
الاليات وضد
مراكز قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي سواء التي
تتحصن في بعض المنازل وتحولها الى ثكنات
عسكريه او الى نقاط عسكريه اقامتها قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي بعد عمليه التوغل في
اطار العمليه البريه التي تشهدها منطقه
خانيونس وتعتبر في هذه الاونه هي ظر
العمليه العسكريه البريه التي يخوضها جيش
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي